und wir müssen diese flut katastrophe
zum anlass nehmen um über den
katastrophenschutz neu nachzudenken und
insbesondere ist zu prüfen warum die
warnmeldungen des europäischen flut
warnsystems nicht rechtzeitig bei den
menschen angekommen sind und das ist
einerseits eine frage der behörden
zusammenarbeit aber andererseits müssen
wir auch prüfen welche technischen
möglichkeiten wir wieder schaffen müssen
oder neu einführen müssen um die
bevölkerung rechtzeitig zu wahren man
darf sich nicht auf ein system verlassen
was wir durchaus brauchen sind lösungen
aber die haben eine begrenzte reichweite
was wir dann brauchen ist die
möglichkeit des cell broadcast in wir
werden aber darüber hinaus auch sirenen
und lautsprecher brauchen ich freue mich
dass herr scheuer die anregung der fdp
aufgenommen hat andere in der
bundesregierung sind ja noch skeptisch
diese skepsis ist verstehe ich nicht
dagegen sprechen verrückter weise
endlich sagen momentan noch rechtsfragen
dieser cell broadcast ring ist in
deutschland nicht rechtssicher wie man
gelernt hat
das muss rasch geändert werden wir haben
in den letzten jahren immer mehr geld im
staat der staat gibt immer mehr geld aus
aber wir stellen fest es sind
überwiegend subventionen und
umverteilung und auf der anderen seite
gibt es ganz kritische kernfunktionen
warum wir einen staat haben
dazu wird der katastrophenschutz bildung
digitale infrastruktur digitale
verwaltung bundeswehr justiz und in
diesen kernaufgaben funktioniert unser
finanziell üppig ausgestatteter staat
nicht mehr in den vergangenen jahren
wurde bei uns viel geld vom staat
eingenommen und es wurde um verteilt es
wurden wahlkampfgeschenke ausgelobt
es wurden subventionen gezahlt
milliarden und abermilliarden man kann
also nicht sagen wie jetzt
politikerinnen und politiker von links
der mitte sagen der staat sei kaputt
gespart worden man müsste jetzt
breitflächig die steuern erhöhen
die wahrheit ist wir sind das höchst
steuer land die öffentlichen haushalte
werden immer größer
und dennoch fließt das geld nicht an die
stellen wo sie hin müssen und das müssen
wir jetzt ändern wir müssen den staat in
seinen kernaufgaben wieder überzeugend
machen damit er in einer veränderten
zeit auch wirklich uns im alltag an den
stellen begleitet nicht im stich lässt
dort wo wir ihn brauchen
und er kann uns lieber verschont von
lästiger bürokratie wenn wir uns
international vergleichen dann ist
deutschland durchaus noch krisenfest mit
dem vergleichen sie uns damit innerhalb
der europäischen union mit israel
hunderttausenden raketen beschossen und
ich sterben weniger leute als bei uns
bei wasser oder wenn wir uns innerhalb
der europäischen union vergleichen haben
sie die niederlande blicken kersting sie
werden mich nicht übertreffen als
oppositionspolitiker das bin ich ja auch
bin ich hier eingeladen als
regierungssprecher trotzdem empfehle ich
immer maß zu halten so schlecht ist
deutschland nicht aber wir einigen uns
sofort deutschland kann und muss viel
besser werden ich rate ab während gerade
noch vor ort die lage bewältigt wird
menschen noch in not sind schon über
abschließende politische konsequenzen
oder die zuweisung von verantwortung da
war genau darauf freuen sich ja darüber
freuen sich ja eigentlich die
verantwortlichen die sagen jetzt gucken
wir mal dahin jetzt helfen wir erstmal
etwas euro weniger persönlich bin
trotzdem nicht verantwortlich für mich
nur vereins verantwortlich für eine
seriöse politische debatte und das
danach geprüft werden muss wie sind
meldungen von wem zu welchem zeitpunkt
beachtet oder nicht beachtet worden
allerdings wer mein wunsch für die
zukunft das nicht in der lage nur
berichtet wird sondern dass vor allen
dingen vorher stadt ist das stichwort
redundanz nicht nur behördlich sondern
auch über die medien informiert wird was
da für eine situation entsteht und wenn
meine sorge ist dass wir durch die
unabweisbaren folgen des globalen
klimawandels die jetzt schon da sind
können wir eine diskussion führen
welchen klimaschutz machen wir mehr
haben schon klimafolgen dass wir solche
schadenereignisse sehen können in der
zukunft öfter sehen können
dann müssen nicht nur die warnsysteme
sondern auch die infrastruktur an
stimmen anderer hochwasserschutz und so
weiter es muss umgehend hilfe geben
soforthilfen hat die bundesregierung und
haben die länder jetzt ja auch schon in
aussicht gestellt wird heute beschlossen
größenordnung sind 400 millionen euro
aus meiner sicht ist das für eine
soforthilfe eine nach aller erfahrung
ausreichende größenordnung soforthilfe
bedeutet ja nicht wieder aufbauen
sondern bedeutet dass menschen die ihren
hausstand verloren haben dass die sich
einfach kleidung kaufen können wenn sie
nicht über die eigenen mittel verfügen
klima haftpflicht die alle mittragen
über solche dinge müssen wir tatsächlich
nachdenken ich sagen warum ich noch
nicht fertig bin mit meiner meiner
meinung es gibt sicher daran die frage
jemand wohnt in einem gebiet wo es keine
elementarschäden zu erwarten gibt über
geringes risiko und andere menschen
leben dort wo es schadenereignisse
häufiger gibt
wie ist es dann mit der prämie man
müsste dann sagen macht eine flatrate
das heißt diejenigen die dort leben wo
es geringere war schaden
wahrscheinlichkeiten gibt zahlen eine
höhere prämie damit dort wo höhere
erwartungen sind die prämien niedriger
sein kann
der nächste schritt in der diskussion
wird aber sein dass menschen sagen warum
soll ich denn mit zahlen wenn jemand
unmittelbar in einer risikozonen ein
neues haus baut muss er denn da bauen
also ich habe noch keine fertige antwort
aber das werden argumente in der
diskussion sei aber erreicht wir müssen
über eine solche klima haftpflicht wie
sie es gerade genannt haben über die
werden wir sprechen müssen weil die
ereignisse sich häufen und dafür müssen
wir nicht nur die strukturen der warn
sms wie sie schreiben schaffen sondern
eben auch bei der frage wie wird dann
irgendwann an schaden wenn der leider
entstanden ist auch getragen
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren